the reason i moved to your country is so
i want to follow my dreams now phil this
is the country you can follow your
dreams in um yeah people will be like
what's your dream chris
[ __ ] follow your dream i want to be a
rapper like not that dream do a
different dream
it's true i love i love rapping i do
freestyle rap that's right that's
improvised it's made up on the spot it's
based on suggestions and so what i want
all of you to do is think of a word a
topic or a phrase you'd like a rap about
um preferably not food or animals just
because they're quite unimaginative be
creative be be mad you know
crazy [ __ ] like 9th century crop
rotation that's one of my favorite ones
one second um let me tell you the best
one because pluto is kind of boring
right you can like i had a german guy
who said a day in the life of an aztec
high priest
yeah wait so
there was a comment before do you was
there were comments about you calling
him daddy during sex is that
yes okay that's cool no don't hey don't
knock it you tried it um
i would like to take that as the first
suggestion because you said pluto but
that's boring but i've never rapped
about it
it was very interesting no i disagree i
think that
i'm just saying usually i'll let you
choose the suggestions no the first one
is going to be that because it's more
insane than pluto and no one's ever said
it before and it's usually quite hard to
find a suggestion that no one's ever
said before because i've done this like
20 years so i want to um get some fun so
did you hand up there
no no you were just like oh i'll move
out of the way for them to take my plate
cool if you have a wrap just let's come
over here what do you guys want to hear
right about frodo frodo baggins cool
thank you yeah thank you for going for
the slightly nicher one as well
yeah cool cool frodo back it's great
frodo baggins daddy sex people over here
what do you like a rap about
space force oh cool yeah yeah that's a
blast from
24 months ago
let's come so the people at the back of
the room on this side what do you want
to wrap up
he said elon musk that comes up a lot
that's boring um
what what ha do you drink tea
red bush tea are you south african you
are south african or diplomatic
community right
red bush tea red bush tea
daddy sex um frodo
baggins you said you said flannels
as it oh as in because flannels ah i see
do you also you call them washcloths
don't you in the uk a flannel is a
washcloth isn't that fun this would be
called a checkered shirt
[Laughter]
so flannel red bush tea
daddy sex frodo baggins um let's get one
one final one
irish independence and steph curry great
and space force this is too many
suggestions but we'll try you may need
to remind me so try and remember all
these we've got space force irish
independence steph curry flannel daddy
sex frodo baggins it's gonna be
absolutely wild and crazy and it is it
is you doubt it but it is because i got
my band they got some beats let's see
which one you're going to pick out your
bag of beach this time
[Applause]
listen to that
i believe that is what we call boom back
it's gonna be good um and let's uh i
will begin with the gentleman over there
who shouted out yes cool
the first word the suggestion coming out
your face get a branch of military up to
outer space taking off maybe cape
canaveral down below where they visiting
definitely not pluto i apologize [ __ ]
suggestion now slam it used to be one of
the nine of the planets and then all of
astronomers they were like nah pluto
you're basically a very big star it
doesn't even count or maybe a moon space
forth donald trump was like income come
too soon taking off there yeah we're new
to this he just likes the movies of
george lucas he was feeling inspired by
the star wars they designed a little
logo on them course all the applause
anybody who gave it an inspect they
would see it's just a low before star
trek they cheated that stuff i'm having
it large why did they have the space
force with the outfit camouflage that
didn't make sense space is an abyss no
one can hear you scream no one can hear
your hiss making any noise i'm having
fun yeah see over the hell in nyc people
at the back let me say it in the place
at the front of the stage you'll be
staring at his face saying this is
amazing please shag me that means sex in
england and call me daddy call me daddy
call me daddy it's so fun if you call
him daddy does he call you mum i try and
make sense of that i'm a goner if i was
saying daddy and she called me mama
that's the back to front way but it
doesn't even matter after having sex
please don't call your dad up and say
sup dad i'm reminded of you i thought i
should give you a bell yeah how do you
do ah that's really cool yeah fun to
handle what you're wearing oh probably
some flannel your dad wears flannel he's
totally fine he'll be out there in the
sunshine unwinding where's flannel same
pattern on the front and back maybe in a
little forest like a lumberjack cutting
down the trees chopping away you'll be
pointing those threes like steph curry
oh a nice link playing for golden state
used to be good used to be great and
he's still pretty good but the team are
more whack he struggles there tried to
keep the team on track he's like come on
guys come on you dudes i'll step up the
threes you sub up the twos he's too
small to dunk still pretty hunky if he's
in the hot hall of fame not the top
three but probably the top ten anyway he
plays good on steph curry i hope you
come back someday doing well and your
team rises to the top now i know we had
some more yeah help me up a lot you can
help me sir shout it out from your mouth
there what's the other suggestion
frodo bangers not bowser that would have
rhymed oh yeah back up on the beat and
i'm trying to take care you were like fb
best hobbit in the room got the big
hairy feet and he's climbing mount doom
granddad bilbo taking out the ring gonna
find the horrible little golem thing yes
further back you should all respect us
no give me the ring no give me back
precious
[Applause]